So, this seems really brain-dead. And before we go further on this, we should do
a sanity check of whether this is actually practical. For a human, it certainly
wouldn't be. If the dates are a few years apart, you wouldn't want to count
every day. But what about a computer? So the question is roughly how long do you
think it would take, using this brain-dead approach, to count the number of days
in a hundred years between December 12, 1912, and December 12, 2012. So here are
the choices. A few nano seconds, that's a billionth of a second, a few
milliseconds, that's a thousandth of a second, a few seconds, a few minutes, a
few hours, or way, way too long. This requires a little bit of guessing or
thought but I think you should know enough to be able to get the correct answer.